inside beyoncé and jay-z's new 90
million dollar mansion and could JLo and
a rod be heading down the aisle now
before we get into Beyonce and JLo it's
another day and another slithering snake
courtesy of Taylor Swift like we're set
today Academy so dramatic
all right it's the second cryptic
reptilian video but I'm afraid I've got
nothing more on her mysterious message
one can only assume it's new music so
dear Taylor just come out with it
already all right Taylor may have wiped
her social media clean making way for
her next era meanwhile beyonce is hiding
nothing
Beyonce gave birth to twins 10 weeks ago
but you'd never know it by looking at
the most recent sexy pics be pulled out
that frickin dress showing off her
curves in this sheer bodycon dress by
house of CBS and get this the price is
only 100 sending on Burke's ladies now
if you're going to be the queen and
dress like one you've got to live like
royalty to Beyonce and jay-z have
officially bunker down in Los Angeles a
source confirms two et the couple closed
on this 30,000 square foot bel-air
mansion the purchase price 19 million
dollars pocket change for line lengths
all right perched up on a hill with a
view of LA the eight bedroom 11 bath
home might just be big enough for the
family of five the two acre property
features four pools lots of outdoor
lounging space there's also a basketball
court room for a recording studio
separate staff quarters and a garage big
enough to park 15 cars now mr. and mrs.
Carter would have some famous neighbors
like Jen Aniston and JLo although who
knows for how long because Jenny from
the block has been spending a lot of
time in Miami with her man a rock yep
j-rod is going strong literally look at
these to work on their fitness at a rock
new UFC gym in his hometown
the couple who works out together
apparently stays together because a
source tells et the pair are solid and
happier than ever in fact those in jail
OHS inner circle see marriage potential
and that JLo quote loves that they're
both
successful in business and they're both
parents source close to Alex as he is
all in and his kids like her a lot in
that what means the most to him JLo is
in Miami spending time with Alex and his
daughters before she heads back to Vegas
for her residency the proud papa live
stream the family night on Instagram and
just look how cute they are
Jennifer what was the highlight of your
summer I would say Paris Paris is the
highlight when I tell you so cute let's
pop up that John and Chrissy scale and
check back in with these two because
they are such a solid nine I mean
serious goals do you agree or not hit me
up in those comments section and if you
don't think they are 9 let me know why I
am curious all right someone who has not
been as lucky and finding love - Mario
Jackson yep we're still talking about
the scandal that rocked bachelor in
paradise and tonight the man at the
center of it all sits down with Chris
Harrison more on that welcome back our
girl lauren zima almost very nice event
let's talk about this tomorrow has been
making the rounds you chatted with him
one-on-one ahead of interview literally
what else is there left to say I know
that's kind of the question because
Demario has given a lot of sit downs and
then we saw kind of what happened in
paradise on the show season premiere and
then now Chris Harrison is sitting down
tomorrow so the question is what is left
to say but when I parted to Mario he
told me that he is a quote wreck during
this interview with Chris Harrison he
cry in my interview and so I would
imagine he really goes to time this
because here's the thing Chris Harrison
ABC they kind of know what they're okay
with airings so Chris could really ask
very pointed questions I think about the
scandal knowing what they be okay
talking about so it's going to be
interesting to watch we talked about
like an hour and a half yes that's what
I talked to contestant Derek path who
was there because they had bachelor in
Paris contestants there in the audience
of course ABC was that branding
everybody was there and he said that
Chris talked to Demario for about an
hour hour and a half also talked to
Corrine and separately we won't see that
until next week they kept them separate
so I think that one maybe we can open up
even more
they're like not worried about with the
other spanking well now we had your
first book at the actual sit-down
between to Mario and Christic look so
what happened on the first day with
curette now we got turns up you know it
was a very I mean it was rough our
hanging out one thing leads to another
and we'll make it out I'm like you and
Corinne Corinne and I yeah and I'm like
oh wow paradise is going I remember I
think it was biggie that's it paradise
is official and right I have my whistle
around my neck I'm blowing that annoying
everybody everybody's on set like I
think I brought like 50 whistles I think
I've none of them and how long was this
into paradise this was quick this was I
mean we were at like hours or minutes
this was like an hour or so like an hour
so oh yeah so pretty quick quick no that
was quick
you know this was this was like in bar
terms we just got to the club we're
already about thing like getting it you
know get out of there but yeah you know
I mean we're there you know we're
hanging out then she's like let's go to
the pool so I mean who would say no to
correct a very pointed comment who would
say no to corral so I talked to Chris
Harrison actually after Mantella from
the Bachelorette where Demario was like
super vocal swearing at I'm didn't cry
though ultimately Chris told me that
after men tell all he wasn't sure how
things would go with tomorrow during
this sit-down so we're gonna see it all
tonight on ABC well thank you born you
guys can of course as always catch up
with Lauren and her bachelor in paradise
recap on today's new episodes of roses
and a it's up right now I have a drink
be safe though thank you girl oh are you
guys that is it for today be sure to hit
subscribe so you don't miss an episode
of daily Denny and roses and rose' and
of course we have all of this and a lot
more up at et online.com so I will see
you guys tomorrow mishima get out eyyy